now I'd like to introduce our featured
presenter today dr. Lou Chia or Annika
Lucia's a lecturer at the Stanford
Prevention Research Center and primary
instructor of the epigenomics and
microbiome X module of the Stanford
genomics certificate at the Stanford
center for professional development
Lucia's currently leading the epigenetic
analysis of the Stanford diet fit study
by Professor Christopher Gardner the
largest randomized clinical trial ever
undertaken to compare low carb vs. low
fat diets for the design of personalized
weight loss strategies the focus of her
research is investigating how diet
affects the epigenome and whether we can
use epigenetic biomarkers to design
personalized weight loss plans
Lucia also serves as an advisor for
companies active in the personal
genomics and precision health field
Lucia received her PhD from the
University of Vienna and has research
experience from the University of Oxford
University of Southern California and
University frederico ii of naples she
has published research papers in
top-ranked peer-reviewed journals such
as cell genes and development and the
EMBA journal and with that let's turn it
over to Lucia so thank you very much for
having me here it's a pleasure to talk
today about unlocking your genetic
potential using the science of
epigenetics and this is an why so my Y
my mission is using science to live
healthier happier life and helping
people achieving this you can follow us
at IP wellness and find more information
at dr. Annika com
I do these through my research and
teaching if my research could be a
painting it will be this painting here
and not because the author Giuseppe
Archibald OH
was Italian as I am the reason is that
Josephus seemed to know that food shapes
our biology and it does so through
through two processes that are the
cornerstone of my research here at
Stanford nutria genetics and
nutrigenomics neutral genetics describes
how genes can affect our response to
diet whereas nutrigenomics describes how
diet can affect our gene expression so
this is like a give-and-take
a sort of conversation and it's a and
this is my main research interest here
at Stanford but I also teach several
courses at Stanford in person and online
and yes you can get notified about new
course launches at dr. Anka calm my
research is the driving engine of my
teaching but my teaching on the other
side is the fuel of my research I get a
lot of motivation from teaching and many
students tell me that they come out of
my courses empowered to use science to
improve their health and I hope that
today I can give you a taste of that and
you can take home some messages
actionable information to improve your
health
so today we will learn about what is
epigenetic and how it is different from
genetics how diet can impact our
epigenetics and health and now
epigenetics can help us take owners
ship on our health so understanding the
difference between epigenetics and
genetics is especially important now
that there are several companies using
genetic testing to predict everything
about us
what we should eat where and even what
kind of music should we listen to but so
all these companies work in the space of
precision health which is a new
revolutionary health care approach
aiming at predicting preventing and
curing disease precisely by using
biological markers that are unique for
so they are pretty weak for people
personalized characteristics and these
biomarkers are genomics epigenomics as
exposomics so the entire set of
environmental factors we are exposed to
metabolomics the metabolites in our body
proteomics all the proteins in our cells
and tissues and microbiome the universe
of microbes within us and on us but most
of the companies in the precision health
space are now using only genomics but we
know that the other omics
scientists they're called lifestyle
omics are actually responsive to what we
do to our environment our lifestyle and
therefore are of particular interest in
the field of preventative medicine and
lifestyle medicine and they can also
enhance the predictive power of genomics
markers were measured alone so why do we
need to integrate genetic testing with
lifestyle omics
markers for precise health predictions
let's have a genetic refresher - in
order to answer this question our DNA is
made of four four building blocks for
nucleotide nucleotides apgc
that provide the information for
building the sequence of the amino acids
in the proteins that build up our cells
and tissues and a multi-billion dollar
project running from the 90s until 2003
the human genome project aimed at
sequencing the entire sequence of the
human genome and genome and there was a
lot of hope behind this project and I
was one of of the people very excited
about this project actually I started my
university studies in 2000 and this was
one reason for me to to decide to inside
to pursue studies in molecular biology
and genomics and scientists were
literally betting on how many genes
would turn up when the human genome will
be finally met and but the human genome
as you may know produce some shocking
surprises
the first shocking surprise was that we
humans have actually the same moral
the same number of genes as a simple
model systems such as mice fruit flies
and worms and 50 times fewer than an
onion
the second shocking surprise was that
genes account for only 2% of our DNA and
if that weren't enough to hurt our
genetic egos
there is a third shocking surprise that
actually your guinea is 99.9 similar to
any other person's DNA so technically
speaking our DNA can explain only 0.1
percent of what make us unique and
therefore is perhaps not surprising that
also my genetic report was not very
accurate in predicting my hair type so
according to my JD report I'm 72% likely
to have straight hair and for the same
reason we were not surprised when we
received the genomic results for our
study the diet fit study this is a study
by Professor Christopher Gardner with
the 609 the overweight and obese men and
women that are randomized to either low
carb or low fat diet that they follow
for one year we are measuring genomics
epigenomics microbiome Ickx proteomic
mass markers for our study and we
publish the results for for the genetic
part and we actually could not
replicate some genetic associations that
had been published previously
associating a three genes in the mucus
and fat metabolism with the prediction
of diet response I'd look up or low fat
and that's why we are now focusing on
epigenetics and we are measuring the DNA
methylation looking for epigenetic
biomarkers of diet response so what is
epigenetics you may remember the 2008
cover of the Time magazine stating that
the new science of epigenetics reveals
how the choices you make can change your
genes and those of your kids so
epigenetics to to understand epigenetics
let's just describe the meaning of the
world that comes from the Greek language
where a key means above on the top so if
your DNA is your genome then your
epigenome is actually a set of molecular
markers chemical groups that are on the
top of your DNA and can switch genes on
and off just like a dimmer switch can
modulate lights up and down in room and
this process of turning genes on and off
can explain why we have different types
of cells in our body liver cells neurons
fat cells all tall
more than 200 types of cells or the tour
shares the same DNA the same information
so how is this possible well think of
your DNA your genome as Hardware then
the epigenome is software that can turn
genes on and off
specifically in different cells so here
each cells each cell will turn off a
Civic set of genes and turn on only
those genes that are required for its
identity and function to understand the
software we need to understand two
fundamental properties of the epigenome
epigenetic flexibility and memory
so unlike genetic sequence our genome is
flexible and dynamically responds to
lifestyle factors and this is both this
Athens already very early in life so
when the egg and sperm fused together
actually they erase all almost all the
genetic marks giving rise to embryonic
stem cells these stem cells can become
any type of cell because they don't have
epigenetic markers to instruct the cell
about which genes to turn on and off but
when during the embroidery fetal
development these cell
do acquire epigenetic marks then they do
start differentiate in the different
types of cells that make up our body and
as you can imagine embryonic and fetal
development are there are time windows
that are particularly sensitive to
lifestyle factors and that's this is a
reason why pregnant women should be
especially careful of their lifestyle
because this can have huge impact on the
epigenome of the developing fetus
there are many lifestyle factors
affecting epigenome diet pollutants
stress drugs chemicals additives and the
way these lifestyle factors can impact
our P genome and gene expression is by
sending signals to enzymes proteins that
either right
erase or read epigenetic modifications
on our genes does affect affecting the
gene expression therefore you can think
of the epigenome as a set of sticky
notes placed on your genes that can
store an epigenetic molecular memory is
called epigenetic memory of your
lifestyle exposures the delicate balance
between flexibility and molecular
stability is what makes it possible for
our cells to store an epigenetic memory
epigenetic marks are flexibly
modified by lifestyle factors but
they're stable through cell division and
can be therefore passed to the daughter
cells and this makes episodic memory
possible now the nodes the markers that
are written before our birth tend to be
written in pen so they tend to be
permanent whereas the notes that are
taken after our birth are potentially
reversible as if written with a pencil
and both pen and pencil marks can affect
our health and place position for
diseases
so while genetic factors can contribute
to our trades through a process of
hardwiring epigenetic markers do so by a
process of soft wiring that is
dynamically influenced by our
environment lifestyle and that's why for
example identical twins that have
exactly the same DNA can with time not
only look different but also develop
different priests position to disease
now there have been a thousand studies
on the impact of diet of on our
epigenetics and actually epigenetics is
an opportunity for us to look at diet
from
a new perspective food is not on the
calories its information is the most
important signal powerful signals to our
genes and it can actually modulate
several of those enzymes that can bright
erase and grid epigenetic modifications
one of the most famous studies in animal
around diet and epigenome is a study
coming from a beehive
so queen bees are much larger than other
bees in a beehive that are called worker
bees they also live longer and they are
first time they can lay eggs
whereas worker bees cannot now what is
surprising is that queen bees and worker
bees are genetically identical and what
is even more surprising is that the only
difference is that only queen bees are
fed royal jelly a protein-rich substance
that is actually secreted by worker bees
and these tells a lot about fairness in
nature and that can actually turn on
specific genes that make the queen
become a queen but before you run to
your local store and buy royal jelly I
have to tell you that this doesn't seem
to work for humans we do have
nutrients that we know are acting
through an epigenetic mechanism and we
are discovering every day new nutrients
in this category
I call these nutrients acting nutrients
these are our royal jelly the nourish
our epigenome and unlock our full
potential here is a table with some of
these at nutrients so the one here on
the left in orange are nutrients that
can actually provide the building blocks
for making the switches epigenetic
switches this include methionine folate
vitamin b12 b6 choline detain and the
nutrients on the right this one in
violet they can actually modulate the
activity of those writers and racers and
readers and so affect our epigenome
these include many polyphenols such as
for example those from green tea
resveratrol from red wine some
flavonoids in soy genestein sulforaphane
a very famous IP nutrient found in all
cruciferous vegetables and broccoli
beauty rate a very interesting nutrient
that is actually produced in the gut
when dietary fiber is fermented and so
it's so so heavily dependent on our
microbiome and then died a little
sulphide or that's from garlic
so all these studies are showing that we
are what we eat but they're even studies
that suggest that we may actually be put
our what our parents and grandparents
ate one of these studies is again an
animal study and these two mice here are
pythons as you can see one is yellow and
fat and the other is brown and lean and
the game surprisingly this micelle
genetically identical they both have a
gene called called
the agouti viable yellow allele or ABY
that genetically programs these mice to
become fat developed yellow fur and
develop late later in life diabetes but
the ADI gene is turned on only in the
yellow fat mouse why actually this is
because of the diet of their the mother
of this mice so for the yellow Mouse the
matter of the yellow Mouse had a diet
was poor in epping nutrients and for
these reasons her daughter couldn't
build the building the the the building
blocks of the epigenome and turn off the
ady a lean during embryonic development
whereas the mother of the Lingga brown
mouse was behaving well and eating all
these a key nutrients was fed the diet
was supplemented with those nutrients
and as a result
her daughter could turn off the ady gene
but what about humans is there some
evidence that we could also be what our
parents and grandparents ate well there
is evidence not from an experiment but
from a historic tragedy this was a Dutch
hunger winter during World War two
there was a food embargo in Holland and
as a result more than 20,000 people died
as you can imagine the the mothers the
the the babies born during the famine
were underweight and had a lot of health
issues and this is not surprising but
what is surprising is that when these
babies became adults they actually
developed well they were more more prone
to develop diabetes diabetes and become
obese and what is even more surprising
is that the children of the fanning
babies had also a higher risk of
becoming obese and developing metabolic
disease although they were never exposed
in to the famine so recently scientists
found out that actually in actually the
the famine babies had persistent
epigenetic changes especially in some
genes regulating metabolism glucose
metabolism and fat metabolism which
suggests that there was there were some
epigenetic marks written in pen during
the famine that persisted later in life
and had long-term consequences of on
the metabolic health of these people and
but not only the diet of the mother is
important also the diet of fathers and
these a recent study showing that
actually the epigenetic marks in the
parent cells of obese people are
dramatically different from those
finding lean people and they are found
in genes that regulate brain function
and appetite which makes sense from a
mechanistically point of view to explain
the problem with the obesity and
metabolic disease and even more
surprising when these people these
people go through but attic surgery and
lose weight also these epigenetic
markers reverse from the obese type to
the lean type so this suggests actually
yo bgt associated epigenetic markers in
sperm cells may actually be written with
a pencil and this brings us to the most
important topic of this lecture we want
to use at genetics to live a healthier
happier life and empower us to take
ownership on our genes and our health
and to do so we should move from a
paradigm of fear of disease to one of
opportunity for health
just think about your genes as the
starting line in your health journey
the good and bad predispositions you
were born with and the lifestyle omics
are your path to health the really the
biology that you build every day by
making your lifestyle choices so high
hope that you can embrace now-why
lifestyle omics
matter and I will show you one one last
example from recent studies in which
researchers identified a polygenic score
able to predict the risk of coronary
heart after a calcification for a heart
disease in people and then they looked
at how these people could actually
predict disease in three different
categories of people some of them at a
favorable lifestyle with the exercise
and healthy food some of them and
intermediate lifestyle here in gray and
then some an unfavorable lifestyle in in
red now as you can see actually even if
you have a high genetic risk here on the
on the on the right in red actually you
have a favorable lifestyle in blue this
can cancel out the your your genetic
predisposition you see it's the blue the
blue bars are the same height in the in
the intermediate and high categories so
it means that basically if you have a
favorable lifestyle here in blue
really doesn't matter if you are you
know a high genetic risk and this is
what I actually hope to have shown to
you in this presentation so I hope that
now you can embrace that we are unique
in many ways and two of these ways are
our genes the book your parents wrote
for you and the other more interesting
book is your lifestyle the book you
write every day and can impact your
lifestyle omics and remember that diet
is one of the most powerful epigenetic
pencils you have in your hands and with
this I would like to thank you for your
attention and yes please follow us at
epi Wellness thank you very much Lucia
for this very important event ation and
now we will move on to answering your
questions the first question here is
what are some recommended readings or
resources to learn more about the topic
of epigenetics I depends on what level
of so if you want a very deep dive I
always recommend the books on the book
on epigenetics I think now is the third
edition by David Ellis and Thomas
genuine that is a wonderful book and
otherwise I do like reading papers that
I know that is a jungle for for most
people I think that's also some some
websites like what is epigenetics that
can be also very helpful so our next
question is how far does the epigenetic
flexibility go regarding diet and does
one meal affect as much as lifelong
dietary habits oh I wish I could respond
a huntress quest answer this question
with a precise answer we don't know we
because we don't have studies that have
compared one single meal versus a
long-term diet exposure but we do know
that actually epigenetic some epigenetic
marks can change very rapidly such as
those that are responsible for example
to trigger new responses we need to
switch on and off those genes very very
quickly and so certainly we can we can
predict it's very likely that even after
one meal your there would be some
epigenetic changes - the big question is
whether these actually matter for your
long-term health it seems that for
example if you want to reverse some
metabolic issues or obesity those
changes require longer exposure for
example longer diet intervention even
the speed of a reversal depends on how
how strong the exposure has been and how
long for example in case of obesity
how long disposer to an obesogenic diet
has been and how long have been
overweight the reason i potus's
according to which actually people may
have harder time losing weight because
of some epigenetic stiffness so the
resistance of some of those pencil marks
to actually be erased so to come back to
your question is really the speed of
reversal is very really an individual
issue so the next question somewhat
related which is are happen happy
nutrients more important
during particular parts of a person's
life for example pregnancy or childhood
yes yes as I as I mentioned in my
lecture pregnancy in childhood are
especially important because the the
fetus during variant development our
epigenome is just being established I
describe it as an naked at dinner or
almost naked so of course the the older
lives environmental signals in that time
window are are going to have a bigger
impact and are going to be potentially
written in pen I also want to mention it
actually it's a good thing think that we
have markers that are written in pen
because those markers are essential to
establish cell identity otherwise we
would have our hair turning into a nose
or something like that so it's good that
those markers that are established
during burning development tend to be
written in pen but the downside is that
some of the markers that are established
for example in response to a bed or
adverse licensure might as well then end
up written in pen okay so the next
question is actually regarding that
which is is there a way to turn off the
genes that can impact health negatively
for example the famine genes yeah again
there is evidence of epigenetic reversal
of some disease associated epigenetic
markers I've sure shown you the example
of the obesity associated markers in the
sperm of of man but actually we saw
smokers smokers
smoking associated epigenetic markers
are exceptionally like very well studied
and actually researchers have shown that
those markers can be reversed after 16
years
so after quitting with smoking so there
is evidence again the speed of reverse
depends on the exposure and the type of
exposure and is a person on the person
is it possible to discriminate if stop
or go signal through CRISPR caste 9 or
similar editing gene system yeah so this
is more like a genetic question right so
you are here your suggestion is to
manipulate actually the DNA sequence we
cannot do that now I mean there is
ongoing research in animal 2 to achieve
that but I'm a believer of you know
lifestyle medicine intervention so
rather than changing the DNA changing
the way it works
the next question is I teach health and
PETA high school students we're starting
nutrition soon any ideas or hints to
change their poor diet for 14 to 16 Wow
so this is a awesome more like more
better genomic question what diet
question so the question what do we know
about what what is the most impactful
intervention we we can do to to improve
our health and perhaps our epigenetics
well for sure there is a consensus on
the reduction reduction of refined
grains and added sugar sugars there are
epigenetic field some
vacations suggesting that sugar can
actually trigger epigenetic
modifications that linked metabolic
disease to other diseases that are
associated to a B city including cancer
so what we know from dietary
recommendation is also a more profound
so indication in our death by all
genetic genetics reduction of refined
grains and sugars is for sure important
than a diet that is rich in fiber to
promote the microbiome there is also now
new research showing actually a
crosstalk between our microbiome and our
epigenetics so those two are our two
areas of very important now and then of
course the the third is quality of food
good quality of fats and and
carbohydrates so carbon is primarily
from vegetables and and facts also from
natural fats not hydrogenated industrial
fats okay so you mentioned the
epigenomic role of the father influences
brain function and appetite control
genes but what about the mother and to
what extent can an unhealthy mother help
reverse any potential damage you might
have superimposed on her unborn fetus
yeah so regarding the effects so the the
the genes that showed differential
epigenetic modifications and expression
in the Fanning babies so for the one
that were modified as a consequence of
the model exposures those genes were
especially metabolic genes so genes
involved in the glucose and fat
metabolism
and as I mentioned the research about
how to reverse those marks is ongoing
there is there is hope
actually genetics is the science of hope
whereas epigenetics during the feminism
may induce people to think okay
I'm stuck with my genetics there's
nothing I can do
epigenetics give us a tool to actually
take action on our health and improve
our health there is research as I
mentioned showing that many of those
marks can be reversed even even those in
the fetus four are not all written in
pen not all the notes written during
embryo Val are written in pen so I think
it's really important to act as soon as
possible in case of children that have
been exposed to adverse environmental
exposures during during a pregnancy it's
important to to act as soon as possible
because also childhood is a very
sensitive time window for the epigenome
and by doing so and focusing on all the
environmental factors that we know can
benefit epigenome diet is one of them
but also these emotional health and
environmental health exposure to
chemicals I'm sure you can optimize you
can minimize the effects of a bad
exposure during the pregnancy and
maximize the likelihood of a track
driving life for your children okay so
there was a couple of additional
questions here and we have a little bit
more time and so someone had asked they
had their entire genome mapped
what should they be asking when they see
the results wow this is a big question
so it's actually very exciting and now
more companies are are offering the
mapping of the entire genome as you may
know there is a difference between a
mapping the entire genome or genotyping
through a service like for example 20
trainee or other genetic testing
companies but now there is also the
question how to use that information
this is a big question here
Jenny testing can be a double-edged
sword so on one side can actually
empower people to take action all of
their health you can say okay I have
this press position to absorb less
folate from my diet so I will eat more
of that but on the other side this can
also trigger some nocebo effect like for
example people can can feel that yeah
they have bad genes and that's not they
can do there is actually an interesting
study published by Stanford researchers
a couple of months ago showing that
people that received fake genetic scores
predicting that they were going to
perform poorly on a treadmill then
actually when they did and they did the
pair the treadmill test and they did
perform poorly but those were fake
genetic scores so my point here is when
you receive this genetic information
there are the there are some genes that
you can look at there are a few genes
that are really backed up by by
convincing evidence and these are
especially genes in the
regulating our response to
micronutrients like folate and also some
other vitamins vitamin B and also the
omega-3 so there's some people for
example that have some genetic
polymorphisms that make us less
efficient at converting plant Omega
threes to biologically active eth DHA so
that there is there is a evidence the
dark or Jerry polymorphisms are backed
by evidence but you should always be
aware that those our complex traits all
our traits even our response to food are
actually degraded by hundred thousand
genes and that's why it's very difficult
to predict them precisely only by
testing one example is height height is
highly genic genetic so isn't easy it's
an extra it can be explained like from
eighty to ninety percent by genes but
because it's affected by more than 100
thousand genes there is actually now no
genetic test that is going to predict
able to believe height so my point here
is yes go look at some there are areas
that you can look at like micronutrients
omega-3 respond so methylation pathways
cardio metabolic health but please be
aware that those are only predictions
with the with the low predictive power
because complex traits are affected a
thousand genes and hopefully one day
when
we will be able to integrate those
general predictions with other
multi-omics markers that I showed you
then we'll be able to announce the
creativity of those markers and and be
more confident about their meaning for
our help thank you all right well
unfortunately we're getting close to the
hour so we'll have to wrap up the Q&A
session thank you very much dr. Orr
Annika for sharing your knowledge with
our participants today for those of you
who have indicated an interest in the
course our team will be reaching out
with more information and you can always
visit us at genetic certificate
stanford.edu as a final reminder the
recording of this webinar will be
emailed to you within a week thank you
all for joining us today and have a
great rest of your week